you also came to the Conan in Berlin
show yes which I we both said is one of
our favorites yes and it's so hilarious
and this segment you're in is yes just
one of the yeah you guys learned the
shoe plotler dance yeah yeah and then
danced alongside these two brothers
these German brothers and their dad and
their dad yeah yeah it's real yeah that
was really fun yeah it was hilarious it
was I mean
started doing the international remotes
and
it kind of just well I mean I we talked
about this a little bit
the in the one that I listened to last
night the first one where you were very
complimentary or complimentary about my
ability to sort of create my own little
corner and be sort of off on my own
little island because right I was on the
top floor in a corner office and you
know kind of I did you know and I and I
also too over the years like I you used
to like to say like the last production
meeting I had been to was in 1993. you
know that's right there'd be a
production meeting every morning first
and last where where you know everyone
would talk about what the bits were
gonna be and you know you'd clear it
with props and even if I'd written a bit
I always felt like well I you know yeah
we're gonna I'm gonna find out anyway
you know I don't need to get there and
be and I was there I was usually there I
just wouldn't go in yeah yeah and also I
loathe meetings they just hate them so I
I didn't you know I wouldn't go to
meetings I wasn't on like the main big
email chain I had delete my assistant oh
you got to filter yeah she filtered what
emails I would need so I was out of the
loop myself but like when oh my gosh you
know that was an option yeah you could
well no you couldn't because you were
running things I was I always like to
say I was the head of my own one-man
Department yeah yeah and uh and even
then sometimes you're like nope yeah
yeah sorry it's above my boss says I
can't
um Andy's not available but
um like when they started
when they started the first one was Cuba
and it it kind of happened and and I was
I was actually supposed to do uh we were
gonna shoot a remote of me being the
Grand Marshal of a Mardi Gras parade
yeah and but it it it so happened that
the Conan thing got booked and it and he
was going to Cuba like five days after I
would have been in New Orleans so it was
just a Manpower man woman power the crew
yeah the crew would they were they were
gonna say you know it was too soon
before Cuba to do my thing and and for
the riders that would need to go and and
edit so uh I still went and I and that
yeah
I got to eat weed brownies during the
whole thing
about about this though I wrote in a I
wrote In Like A little homemade kind of
um like Rickshaw bike thing and that
some guy behind me and he had a big
coffee can full of weed brownies that he
was just eating constantly what as he's
like pushing you know riding a bike my
big ass around New Orleans but I had so
I got to go down there and just have fun
I didn't have to worry about making TV
and uh and then the Cupid thing happened
and I was and then I remember one time
in the monologue meeting going like well
is it going to be like uh
two Acts or are we gonna do it as
different acts throughout the week and
everyone was like no it's its own
special it's its own hour-long special I
was like oh and then you know and then
as they started to stack up I would I
started to feel a little left out you
know I started to feel a little bit like
you know like I'd like to go on a trip
to a different country right so when the
Germany thing came around I mean and it
was it
you know and he
in you know it made he took people that
it made sense like to take Stephen young
to Korea Persona to Armenia yeah it
makes sense to like me to Korea you know
like I like kimchi you know um so it
made sense to take me to Germany just
because of my last name and whatever you
know and uh but it was so it was so much
fun in a way because I mean you guys
know better than I do those are very
kind of seat of the pants yeah and I got
to fly first class on Lufthansa uh-huh
so nice oh my God so nice the Germans
really have figured out like the sea
like the chair was just it was like it
was like if what like a BMW was a
Rolls-Royce or something and just
like German uh flight attendants that I
I I feel like I like they I don't I may
be transposing to something else but I
feel like they were wearing gloves like
yes yes yeah yeah
because I know in in Alitalia when you
fly Alitalia as you board they're all
wearing these like fantastically uh
beautiful brown leather gloves that fit
perfectly right and I want to say that
the German uh flight attendants had that
but I don't think they did but but it
was just like you know would you like
some champagne and I'm you know kind of
agnostic about champagne but sure sure
and then it's like holy that's the
best champagne I've ever had in my life
right you know movies are better on
airplanes yeah
and then we stayed in a beautiful old
hotel right that um had bullet holes in
it from from World War II yeah because
it had been a bank or something and and
partisans that hold up in it or
something you know and uh I wanted their
money out and my whole experience of
that trip was
me you know having dinner with you guys
and then what's tomorrow like well we're
going out to shoot some stuff in the
morning we'll be back around one okay so
I got your call time I got yeah I got
from when I wake up until one to go
wander and I just yeah yeah I remember
you bought yes I bought some artwork and
stuff like oh well not I mean old prints
and stuff right but I just and I if I
had it to do over again I would have
done because I kind of just decided I'm
just gonna because I hope you know the
hotel was in a nice area I'm just gonna
go that way you know like I'm gonna
wander yeah just wander and not really
and then as I would go I'd kind of read
up on things you know like what I was
seeing
um but it was about like three or four
days of that and then and then I you
know like one day I think like I just
wasn't used at all right you know and
then and then it would be you know we'll
need you at one and then emailing and
you know I'd get an email or a text you
know we're we're not coming back until
three yeah all right so we push it till
three and then it's like probably five
yeah you know so I just kept having more
and more time to just hang out in Berlin
and I had never been to Germany so it
was really oh yeah I was really have you
been back or was I no no I I would like
to go sometime but then that with the
with the brothers was
yeah it was pretty funny and I mean and
that uh oh yeah one of my favorites and
Bunny the one and then again the thing
that I will take away from that was at
one because the brothers were there's
all kinds of acrobatic that they do
yes holding each other upside down and I
tried to do that with Conan right while
he slap supposed to be slapping my butt
right and upside down he was missing my
butt and slapping the backs of my legs
so hard that like when I got back to the
hotel it was just like Conan when Prince
stinging red hands like smacking the
hell oh and I was and I was like going
you know and I think I even said to him
like less realistic if you want to do
that again please hit my butt this time
because the butt has the nice padding
and he also was not holding back no he
was wearing
I remember that was one take yeah just
kind of like okay yeah yeah and then we
and then we ended the thing
in this crazy and this was again like
just seemed like so berliny to me a
nightclub that was in an old building
right it was like eight walk-up stories
and they were different some people
lived on some floors and other floors
were produced people like maybe doing
heroin yeah stairwell from the 60s yeah
and then there was like uh you know like
one floor is just a bar yeah oh and then
the next floor down you're like oh
people live here we can't just go in
there and um and then a giant Courtyard
with like 300 people yeah yeah and then
I was only used in that a couple of
times
it was like me and you know Conan were
supposed to be DJing yeah and it's like
me and flula were together looking yeah
looking uh you know disproving and uh
and then so it was like it was like six
hours of just kind of hanging around in
this crazy weird nightclub and yeah
getting to wander a little bit uh and
then I left and then I heard them like
like that after a certain point the
entire Place becomes like a free-form
sex club and then a few of our crew
members were you know
yeah I left before that yeah some people
were letting their hair down I think I
don't know exactly which hair well I
don't know
I don't know I was I was well and yeah
you know yeah yeah
winking blinking and Nod land
okay